a couple of weeks ago I interviewed
vivica Novak from McClatchy about her
team's investigation into funding from
russia to trump specifically through the
NRA the National Rifle Association and
this was the type of interview that it's
very interesting but it often doesn't do
super well like I don't think when the
interview was over that we thought this
interview is gonna hit a nerve it's
gonna do incredibly well and blow up but
it actually did hit a nerve on a couple
of fronts one is that the YouTube clip
for that interview with vivica Novak was
immediately brigaded by the types of
comments that often end up being the
troll BOTS and the Russian bots online
spreading disinformation anytime
anything critical of Russia is mentioned
but secondly it also did quite well it's
got about a hundred thousand views so
far and neither of those is that common
for a 15-minute interview with a
McClatchy reporter about something
related to campaign finance and
following the money trail and now the
story is blowing up even more this
Russia NRA Trump funding story has sort
of gone mainstream and the NRA is acting
really really shady about it
Democratic Senator Ron Wyden wrote two
letters asking about some of these links
between the NRA and Moscow and between
the NRA and Russian Nationals and the
NRA is refusing to answer the questions
that Senator Wyden has asked they sent
out this really aggressively worded but
lacking almost any specific details
letter basically just saying hey listen
we follow election law and we don't
accept foreign funds period and that
it's really the Russian dude who
allegedly gave them money that's being
investigated not the NRA basically
saying senator Wyden leave us the hell
alone
now of course the letter from the NRA
doesn't actually address the specific
allegations including that NRA officials
went to Moscow in late 2015 it doesn't
address the source of the thirty million
dollars in funding that the NRA gave to
Donald Trump it doesn't address the
broader funding of the NRA by Russia
beyond specifically for Donald Trump's
campaign and it also doesn't exist
doesn't address the existence of shell
companies that are reportedly being used
for this funding in other words this is
getting way more interesting what
started with us as a story that while
very relevant did not have sort of
mainstream penetration when I see this
non denial I become more convinced that
vivica Novak and McClatchy and her team
are onto something with their reporting
and that yes the NRA is accepting money
from Russia and what people need to
realize sort of at the highest level in
the broadest scope is that the NRA is
not a patriotic organization even by
Trump's use of this horrible slogan
American for America first the NRA is
not an America first organization the
NRA uses the idea of being patriotic as
marketing for themselves to then
actually work on their real loyalty
which is to gun manufacturers period it
has nothing to do with country for the
NRA it has nothing to do with safety for
the NRA it has nothing to do with
anything other than give us money which
we can use to get more guns sold for our
clients who are the gun manufacturers
that's the reality and it didn't used to
be that way the NRA started as a gun
safety organization it was geared
towards the individual members and it
wasn't only a few decades ago that they
started taking money from those gun
manufacturers this is all just
corrupting influences remember that uh
that Wayne LaPierre video from 1999 yeah
that he advocated for gun-free zones in
schools
you never see that today I actually read
and I I don't have it in front of me I'm
going off memory but there was a prior
either director or higher up of the NRA
who actually correct me if I'm wrong but
I believe he said something like I don't
even own a gun myself like I don't even
like the idea of carrying a firearm but
we're here to we're going to defend the
Second Amendment because it exists I
don't remember what that was I mean it's
almost kind of does seem logical it's
it's shocking that we are so shocked by
that
so listen the NRA they'll go to Russia
they'll ignore the shootings
strategically they'll flaunt the
American flag and a bald eagle or
whatever other symbols they'll use but
fundamentally this is a marketing and
lobbying organization for gun
manufacturers period now you can say I
like that I like organizations that
ignore public health and country and
everything else just to sell guns or you
can be against that but you have to
understand what it is too honestly and
sort of accurately analyze it and a lot
of people don't they see the NRA s
that's patriotic organization what it
really is is a truly horrible lobby for
the gun manufacturers and in the
meantime the distract the thon continues
it's not is Obama using the wrong
mustard but it's what what's going on
with Hillary's emails and what's going
to be going on with this investigation
into Russia funding Bernie Sanders and
meanwhile this is a really big story
that we've been covering that has been
mostly ignored by corporate media and my
hope is that it now does go mainstream
Russia's interest in doing this if
you're wondering like why would Russia
even want to fund the NRA Russia's
interest in doing this is to create
chaos the NRA is interest is having more
money with which they can promote gun
sales and missing from both of their
goals is anything that would be good for
the actual people of the United States
do not misunderstand for a second what
the goals are of each player in this
entire fiasco the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership